okay for people joining this live stream
we are looking at some design reviews
for
upcoming version 13.1 of awesome
language
and we are talking today about machine
learning i think we have more than one
design review today first one here is
about machine learning
okay
we've talked a bit about feature impact
plot before haven't we
yes
during our tracking meetings
so
those are gonna be the biggest new
feature
it has the biggest impact and it's the
biggest new feature and that's why it's
called the feature impact plot
exactly and we hope to show something
that's why it's called plot
right
um
okay let's take a look here
oh
i really wish you wouldn't do that i
really wish you wouldn't do this
this
putting multiple things on one line like
that oh yeah i speak to the others i
forgot that sorry
i mean i don't know whether that i mean
i suppose in this particular case
okay what are you really showing here
let's let's take a look here so
really i mean why don't you put
an iconized piece of data that exactly
is of the form you want so you don't
have to
mess around with a lot of stuff
or maybe maybe you'll have to anyway i
don't know you need it's after training
you you need a model i i could put a
trained model there i could just start
with model equal the output of the
classifier
i mean model the classifier function no
i think this is good to show the
classifier i think i think
uh
okay so let's understand what this is
doing
oh boy so you've got an actual word
impact that you're putting in there
uh yeah we're gonna remove we're gonna
remove the
the label i was discussing this with
roger
generally speaking these functions are
probably a week away from being fully
cooked like you would expect them to be
they're close but they're not fully okay
all right fine so
what we're showing here
i don't really understand this if you
scroll up to the
the beginning of the notes i tried to
put like a very simple example at the
beginning so what we are showing is
for each example you get you give
and and if you select me in the feature
you select we show the feature on the
horizontal axis and the impact it has on
the classification or prediction on the
vertical axis
so for example this is completely
obscure this can be explained better
i agree
this is
yes okay so what are you actually
plotting
you're plotting
the value explain this plot please
okay so there's one one point one dot
for each example i got that on the
horizontal axis i there's a value of the
one feature that you select
if you want multiple features you are
going to have multiple plots and on the
vertical axis there is the
the sharp value technically and
tell me what that means so that means
how much it deviates from its examine
mean so
there's a there's a mean value let's say
that you didn't have this example what
would be the value basically
and if you have this example how much
does this add to it or subtract to it
from what from
so like if you don't have
if that s i is zero it means that that
example had no impact on the
feature it wouldn't change the value
what what do you mean on the feature no
or on the result on the results what
result
of the classifier or the predictor
so i'm predicting some possible results
what are you predicting
i i'm predicting so you you give me one
person i want to predict the credit
score
okay okay okay so uh what is the impact
on its age on the credit score
okay so you should say
okay so what this is doing is
it's plotting
and and i don't understand what this is
doing
oh because this is a classifier it has
more more than one class so
there's the impact for the free
classification which is not the same
okay so you're not making that clear in
the okay so
in in the first case
okay so what this is showing if we cut
out the three things because that's
already confusing well you can look at
the one below there's a single class i
understand that but i'm saying in the
examples don't give the three case first
yeah
the case to give first is
i wonder whether there's something with
synthetic data where it's really obvious
what's going on
and also it's really simple for predict
because predict has one value
so i'm saying how much would this turn
my value up or down because in the
classification case we're dealing with
probabilities really more gods
actually
if you scroll down there is example for
predict that should come first it's much
much easier
to get the result
no no it was there i don't know why it's
about it okay all right fine but it's
looking like one one of the four that
you see in the grid it's a single
feature that that affects the result
well that's what you should explain
first
and then you should say
you know here plots it for a predictor
okay and then you should explain that
for a classifier
it will show
you know by default it shows each you
know give the signature here by default
it shows
all of the classified all of the
possible classification outputs
right
yep
correct and then or you can specialize
it which is i think what you're doing
here
right yes
right so you've got to show that
signature up in the um
in the main documentation blog
make sense yes
and let me just try to understand
um
so
you're showing for a given data value
you're showing what value of this
feature did it have what value does it
have of that feature
yes and
so the big picture is
this is a way of characterizing the
effect of a given feature
on the result
exactly so the imp is a plot or the
impact of the feature
on the result
okay so this is really hard to
understand
and this is
really hard to understand right and this
is also very hard to understand mean
values and so on that's hard to
understand use predict as roger has said
so it's literally the value you know how
much does this have
what effect does this have on the
predicted value isn't that correct
that's what this is in that case
yes
no that's not the predicted value it's
it's the deviation i mean we could add
the predicted value and then not say no
it is no no no no well we could do that
too but this is the change in the
predicted value delta
prediction
exactly it's it's a delta it's a delta
yes delta on the prediction
associated with
and you should say that i mean this is
utterly obscure here
this this should say
now again i'm i'm
if i
remove one of these points
it's saying
how much the value will change is that
correct
it's not really if you remove the point
it's like if that feature were missing
you would stay on the horizontal line
because you have the specific value
that example is goes down or goes up
so it's about the feature if you don't
have the feature is literally missing
then you stay you you just use the
average but because we have a specific
value for the future
we have a different result
no but i don't understand what's the
significance each individual example
oh the example are providing uh
some distribution because it means you
you need examples to see what's going on
no no no you're not explaining this okay
let's go through this again okay
you got a bunch of dots so what we're
saying is so so what confused me stephen
is this kind of like a parametric plot
where the parameter is example
so for each example we get a feature
value and a feature impact
yes i understand so this is implicitly
showing a distribution
yes and keep in mind that each example
has other features that you don't look
at i i understand that's not relevant to
this this is saying
this is saying
what is
here's a way to explain it
what is the distribution of effects
on the value
okay so let me let me try and write it
as i might write it
okay okay
so
it shows
the
distribution
of effects
on the output
contributed
let's see
contributed by examples with different
values of a given feature but that's not
quite right
the thing is the examples are like a
proxy they're not so important per se
well so you're just showing the
distribution okay
a distribution of effects on the output
of
associated with
data
effects on the output
okay so it's basically
okay
it's basically how much effect
does this feature
in the data
have on the output exactly
okay so if we lead with that somehow
um
shows the i mean it shows the shows
plots
plots um
there's a plot illustrating
the effect
that
and so
um let's see what's the arrow thing
first of all yeah the first arrow thing
that's
of okay so let's say we say okay
so if we say hold on
if we are actually experimenting with a
different syntax to avoid the three the
double arrow to use the feature in the
second argument which is okay all right
okay but what is the other that's the
detail okay all right data
let's say data comma feature
is it data or is it the model
sorry model model i am sorry
model comma feature
gives a plot illustrating the effect
that
let's call it feet whatever
um
that oh you guys say the featured feet
has the the feature
feet
um
wait no wait a second how's hold on as
on the
all right that's so badly set but i mean
and um
uh gives a plot let's change the effect
that
i mean it's roughly this is it not yes
yes
all right the fact that the feature
um
for a trained
model mod whatever it's called
um
of the
of the feature feet
in the underlying data
for a train model mod
has
on the output of the model
okay gives a plot the impact
that the feature feet
look at this
and the underlying data for a trained
model mod has on the output of the model
yeah it still makes sense yes
actually what it is
it's not really quite this it's not as
the impact that the
a better way to say it might be
that the values
of the feature feat
[Music]
is that right or is that not right i
mean because you're plotting in the end
no it it is a value yeah it is the
presence of the future with that
specific value
impact
the values of the feature feed and the
underlying data for a trained model have
on the output of the model it's not
terrible
it's not terrible
and then you can go on and use the um
yeah i i can introduce data to give
like some more like some specific data
you want to you want to use for the test
and uh
well i mean is it the case that you
could make synthetic data
where this is exactly what happens this
is why the first argument doesn't have
data
no no no no no i'm i'm saying i'm saying
a little bit but but what you're doing
here is
when you make that plot you're taking
all of the training data from the model
right
i'm using the the
uh missing value synthesizer of the
model to generate
really
so that's fake data
yeah it's interesting is this what the
hell is this plot
i don't understand i don't understand
why are you not doing
what you're really planning trying to
plot as a distribution
this is a really confusing plot
if that's fake data
i thought that was the real data that
was used for the training of the model
well that's not stored in the model
that's lost
if you have it you can you can pass it
and see the effect of that
but what what you are studying is on the
data is the model is how the model
reacts on some input
okay
and the sentence oh wait wait wait wait
wait wait it's not correct this is
[ __ ]
no wait we're not correct it's not
correct it's giving the sense that this
is underlying data for a trained model
which to me suggests the original data
gives a plot of the impact
that feature feat
in
okay wait a minute the value of the
feature feet
in
a
oh yeah yeah look here's a way to do it
the impact the value of the feature feat
um
in input
to a
trained model
will
have on the output of the model
value
here's the plot of the impact the value
of the feature feat
in input to a train model will have on
the output of the model i believe that's
correct and then what you explain is
that you're using
you know how you indicate that plot
it's the value of that feature how in
the input so in other words
if i've got input that has that value of
the feature
yeah it goes to that but i'm expecting
that it will have that delta so if if in
a vertical slice here i have a certain
distribution that's going to give me the
probability distribution
exactly
for that feature value of exactly that
though of the change in the output
yeah and then the spread is due to the
other features
i understand so if i were to plot
if i were to do a very simple thing here
if i were to make a model
where it is a trivial model
where it just gives me
the output
is you know a linear function of the
feature value
right
is a line for example yes right so you
should show that
yes
you should show that and then then
uh and then you should say
if there are other features if there's
one feature right if the whole data is
just one feature
if if this is just a function right
okay so the first thing to do is to show
if there's one if it's a function of one
variable f of x
then this picture is basically a picture
of f of x
is it not
yes
okay so show that first
okay we we some offset uh due to the
average but yes
yes
right
so show that first then say then put
another feature in there
and say now there's a distribution for
every point
yeah it makes a lot of sense actually
right
yeah and and and um
uh
okay then people have a fighting chance
of understanding what the heck this
thing is
okay should i save this notebook
somewhere
please
my gosh why do i not have machine
learning
well i have no on that framework
okay
okay
so feature impact cumulative plot really
we've got 17 versions of this
incomprehensible thing
well they show different things
which might happen they're
incomprehensible in different ways
exactly
it's it's you know like the
the
[Music]
the
impact
oh it's not built so it's it's not going
to be there oh
well okay so maybe you can show this to
me no no it is it is easy yes it is in
the source
it's in the source
if you scroll down there's a related
link the first one it's going to be that
yep
oh my gosh
what the heck is this
actually this is very nice it's uh
it's basically the
the
so if you have you know feature one two
three
how much do they cumulatively impact
you sure i'm saying
if you can sort the features in a
certain order
as you go down from the least impactful
to the most impactful or maybe the other
way around yeah yes that would be pretty
good yeah
yeah it shows basically for this for
this prediction the wine quality first
volatile acidity is splitting the data
set a lot
then i add alcohol and i have other
splits and then more and more and more
and at the bottom i fall down on the
final result okay so so what it what
this is
is a parallel axis plot basically yes
yeah if you scroll down
parallel access plot if you scroll down
we have the virtual implemented with
parallel axis
okay
we don't have a vertical one but yeah
we will get one yeah it's okay okay i
understand so
so then that would say
is this again synthetic data
no i'm passing it
this sample for example uh with a two
argument form i use the sample so if you
password one example in picture impact
plot can you give it actual data as well
yeah yeah you need all of them
so you can actually analyze one example
if you want specifically
in this case if you analyze one example
you get one dot
yeah exactly not not very informative i
mean that that that that syntax there
doesn't have the data right so i know
i don't think it's bad to have i think
it is better to have the multi-arrow
thing than it is to have the data off in
the 17th argument
no i agree
what i was thinking that
when we talked about this because the
two things that the branch is on there's
model and model plus data so that should
be in the first argument
but then we have what was the two things
in the second there's feature and
featuring class
featuring class yeah so it's just
feature for the predictor and featuring
class for the classifier
i'm not sure that the data
okay but what you've got to explain here
okay feature impact cumulative
are you sure it shouldn't be called
cumulative feature and backplot
uh i mean we created a family of names
that was like kind of mirroring each
other to to suggest that there's uh they
are for the same purpose i understand
i'm open to
but i mean to me
well this is not the cumulative version
of the feature impact this is a
cumulative version of the summary plot
actually
which you might want to look
side by side
so this is a non-accumulated version of
the other one
so you just look at the pure sharp value
here so you can see the distribution of
sharp values for all the features
so compared to the to the the original
feature
yeah you you lose on some because you
don't see the feature anymore but you
you gain the the insight of the dataset
with dataset
okay
so this one is much easier to explain
yeah kind of yep
this one is the effect on the value
for every data point
it's the effect that that feature value
has on the final result exactly
don't we already have this isn't this
some shap values thing isn't this exact
we are promoting this to top level and
adding a full family of functions to do
the of machine learning but that was
this obscure property of classifier
measurement
now is a fully fledged visualization
function
maybe i mean this one is the least
incomprehensible in my view
and also it's the one where you're going
to put all of the data in
wait a minute
these features
they're not necessarily named right no
it could be f1 f2 f3
if you don't give them uh
you you can pass a feature a few feature
names to specify the name
afterwards but yeah
if you don't know what they are they're
just gonna be feature one for you too
okay
and
i'm a little confused about the x scale
for each of these features
that is if i'm looking at this plot and
i want to compare
that's the impact yeah it's not a
feature with the impact
so it's the same scale
i see
okay so this function
okay let's let's go through these again
i think it's super confusing these
functions are named as similarly as they
are
okay
um we have a super long list of
alternate names for all of them
because of this reason
so this is the only different one
the only different one of all four that
are each different we've got an even
more different one exactly because he's
the only one that is not using sharp
values
this is plotting the the model output
directly
so for example this is a survival
probability given the age for for
different uh different
these are crazy if i might say so
okay so first of all
okay let's describe what these are
wait a minute what is this what is this
this is plotting this is the
distribution is that correct
yeah this is a logistic regression so
it's uh the pro it's a probability the
probability of survival is going down
with the age
this is what is called in the literature
ice plot individual conditional
expectation
just to say that i'm not making this up
okay let's go through again what this is
so this is what what are these different
curves here
like they are the examples at the time
passing so each example we have
different uh
class
in the
on the ship and a different uh sex
and and what happens if i take it and i
move and i vary so i have basically what
happens if i take different people and i
change their age leaving every
everything else constant but but
how did it know to pick four of those
uh no i i passed ten but some of them
are the same sex and class so it
collapsed to four
i did a random sample of 10.
okay wait is it
but the number of data points here
is just 10. is that right exactly so
would be i would have 10 lines but some
of the lines they are multiple each
other because they are the same
so
in the model
okay
you could have taken
a person with a specific age
who has various features
that are okay so all features are
determined except one feature is being
varied
exactly
so this allows you to see groups like in
this case like no matter what the the
other features are there's a downward
trend with age
you know i hate this stuff so much you
know i i was planning like 30 when we
first built
first version of mathematica from
language i was planning
to try and clean up the field of
statistics and not to have all of this
kind of telling jokes by numbers
nonsense
where you know there's just some oh
we've got an anova plot with this thing
and that thing and you know oh if we
just compute the such and such value
and then you run into people who say oh
yeah i really i'm really interested in
the blah blah value
that's the indicator i always pay
attention to
and i thought maybe we could clean that
up and have things where we could
actually explain what was going on and i
eventually i just i gave up
because it seemed like people just you
know you talk to people use that stuff
they just say oh yeah i use the the
ranked wilcoxon test that's the thing i
really like
it's like what is it and they say uh
well i don't know i kind of learnt about
it ages ago and some statistics class
i've long ago forgotten but that's the
thing i always look at
and it's just like you know people who
assess companies will say things like
you know
for stock trading and things they'll say
i always look at the um blah blah blah
thing
so
what's my point here my point is
if these things have names in the
literature
but they're freaking incomprehensible
you know maybe the only use is people
who already know
you know who already learnt
in their
you know whatever oh yeah i should
really care about the ice plot or
whatever it is
well i think there's some added value
like uh maybe not for all four of them
but like the
for example the the cumulative function
i think it really explains very well
where each example is going feature by
feature what do you say you're saying
the plot is good or you're saying that
the name is look the question is
i don't care about the name in this case
i'm saying that the plot is informative
i think that this will be used largely
in the same way that things are used in
statistics as as a report that says hey
this is a good model because look at all
the
corroborating i know but so what does
one indicator statistics in that regard
i mean to me i was usually like the
plague i always try and get you know an
explicit plot where you can understand
what the plot is of
and whenever it's something
incomprehensible it's it's like a wimp
out it's like people who write
you know it's like yes you can put a
super words together and maybe they're
trying to say something but it takes a
lot more effort to get that that
collection of words to be clear
and similarly people can say well i put
a plot it's in my paper it's in my
report whatever
be happy
but the fact is with effort with real
effort you can unscramble it to the
point where it's a very clean thing
where you know you can explain exactly
what the plot is of but most people
can't be bothered and they just put in
some random plot
yeah i mean as you correctly pointed out
now and i said two this is not quite
cooked in terms of our as explaining it
or the aesthetics or there's a lot of
things that needs a little bit more no i
understand but i'm asking about the
principle here of okay
like a histogram okay
people understand the idea of a
histogram and then there are lots of
tweaks to it
sure
a quantile plot
i don't know some people understand that
it's not too hard to understand
right
by the time you get into some of these
more i mean some kinds of plots like for
example
a well a parallel access plot not too
hard to understand
the question is are these plots
you know can we get them to the point
where they're consumer understandable
and our best chance is in the name
what what's an example of another kind
of plot where
you know a lot of kinds of plots we have
okay these indicators how about
non-parametric smooth kernel density
estimator
we don't use that name but that is
that is a name used
then that's basically like what
yeah move histogram
no i know
but calling into smooth histogram what
do we call it in fact i think we do
actually call it a smooches
that's
you know it's like that's what people
think of it as and yes it's a kernel
density estimator blah blah blah
uh
i mean we've had some trouble in the
spatial statistics area also with these
incomprehensible things which i think we
managed to
iron out
well if
the the if you want to drop the whole
naming scheme the the cumulative one is
called waterfall plot which makes a lot
of sense
no
no
but no i mean that has to do with
particular layout
yeah no
look let's try and understand what could
we call these plots we're starting from
scratch and let's start off with this
one
um
this one is
you know that one basically is
let's just see it's some kind of feature
i can bring up we have a super long list
of these names
okay explain to me in one sentence what
is this plot
i mean i already know but tell me what
you want is it the dependency
of the
of the model result
from a specific feature value
or okay so
how how the how the model uh
model is conditioned depends by a
specific feature value
model feature dependence
okay so it is roughly a feature value
dependency plot
is it not
yep
er other names we had for these were
yeah feature dependency plot
feature prediction dependency plot
feature partial dependency plot
and all the family
okay
future value dependency plot
okay what would this
okay
then in in that family if we're just
naming them by what what we think you
know so let's talk about the cumulative
one here
okay
that's the accumulated feature
dependency plot
no it's not
it's not well it's not a feature
dependency no it's not valid no no right
value
right
well there's no dependency though here
there's more like there's an impact or
effect or something like that
i see
okay so this one here
that that could also be called feeder
impact plot
we call it summary because we didn't
know what to call the other one but this
is a non-accumulated version of the
other one so if you drop accumulated
that's the featured impact plot
you meant yeah
yeah
but that's really a list plot isn't it
yeah also also the first one is
actually this is a chart this chart
sorry distribution chart with the custom
display function
but yeah
there are other ways you could show that
too you know that we have uh well with
little histograms and things okay so in
this case okay so the most
incomprehensible the thing you were
calling feature impact plot here
yes
what really is that
so this is the super detailed one
you know so this is yeah yeah this is
this is as zoomed in as we get right
pretty much
um
well no but it's the feature impact plot
it's this one here
yeah where i take only one axis and i
expand on the other axis i put the
feature value which here is not present
so is is that that single axis uh yeah
spread over with the future value
oh feature value impact plot impact
impact
yes
now you could imagine doing that in more
than two dimensions right you could
imagine
two features
could you not
oh yes you mean instead of instead of
putting the two plots side by side uh
you just do it the 3d version of that
yes
well no but this is okay feature value
impact plot
okay so this one
so let's just just um
okay feature impact plot here
um
shows
the effect
the impact
of
the value
of each of the features
on the result of a model
it features a value of each of the
features on the results
each of the features
in
the data
each of the extracted features in the
data
on the result of a model
each of the individual features maybe
yeah okay that's nice because we are
like splitting them apart here okay so
the impact of the value of each
each individual feature
or just each feature
well in the data so you're actually
going to give the data probably in most
cases in the first signature here
yeah
i i could i could have a database for
and then and then drop it yeah yeah
right
so then here
this is saying
well shows the cumulative
then this would then say
shows the cumulative impact
of the value of each feature in the data
on the result of a model
yes
okay
so here
shows the dependency
of the result of a model
on the value
of it of
a particular feature
in
data
yep
okay
okay this one here
um
uh dongs on our live stream is
commenting really feels like you could
replace feature with parameter and have
something that would be useful in
classic regression
that's an interesting claim that we
could apply this also to our regression
stuff
yes probably well that if you if you
scroll uh up in the first
page that you have here
we can convert a fitted model into a
predictor and use it here
yeah
what this
person is pointing out
is that with our very traditional
regression stuff
yes but that's what actually um
julia's already done so fitted model can
be used to simply oh i see great
so the only question is the name feature
which is not what regressionoids use
right they use parameter
i don't think that's terrible i think
feature is the modern parameter
do you agree i mean that's my impression
uh i i will add an example for
discoverability that says
you know show the dependency of the
yeah absolutely in regression
right
okay but we also put this on guide pages
we're talking about regression okay
let's do this and then we got a wrap
here
um
feature
value impact plot okay
this was an interesting exercise by the
way trying to grind this into something
that is
even vaguely comprehensible
well thank you you just saved an hour or
several hours of my time probably
right
okay well let's see whether we can nail
the last one
okay so feature value impact plot
okay
shows actually we want to say all of
these want to be plots
give some plots
blah blah okay
plots the impact
of
the value
of a given feature
on the results
of a model is that correct
that's pretty simple
yeah
it's getting closer to what is actually
there but
what's the impact of the input feature
yeah uh
this one we have now here is i think is
better
the input feature values is a bit yeah i
mean this is better to say feature value
impact feature value impact plot
yep
tells you it's the impact of the value
of a feature
exactly
it's pretty descriptive
okay
well this still
sounds like a family
yeah
i'm not too worried about that i think
that um
uh
and actually the one that is plotting a
different thing has a different final
name in the third place which is nice as
well
what do you mean
but the dependency plot it doesn't have
impact which is nice
all right i think we got it okay well so
i'm afraid we're going to have to go on
with a separate meeting
go ahead
the the rest is is uh is a lot smaller
so i mean i envision is it's going to be
probably
when i
implement this stuff what we have here
we can probably review this quickly and
then go go very quickly through the rest
okay uh i mean clearly we need to talk
about but not
yeah i mean
right there's more strategic issues to
talk about exactly exactly but that's
yeah it's not design review for 13 1 is
more likely exactly strategic directions
fine okay good stuff all right thanks
very much and